the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so yeah so we're going to continue to
talk about trig integrals and trig
substitutions this is maybe the most
technical part of this course which
maybe is why professor jerison decided
to just take a LIGO a wall just now and
let me take over for him but I'll do my
best to help you learn this technique
and it'll be useful for you so we've
talked about trig integrals involving
sines and cosines yesterday and there's
another whole world out there that
involves these other trig ID trig
polynomials trig functions secant and
tangent and let me just make a little
table to remind you what they are
because I have trouble remembering
myself so I enjoy the opportunity to go
back and remind myself of this stuff
let's see the secant is one over one of
those things which one is it it's weird
it's one over the cosine and the
cosecant is one over the sine course the
tangent you know it's the sine over the
cosine and the cotangent is the other
way around so when you put a KO in front
of it it changes it exchanges sine and
cosine well I have a few identities
involving tangent and secant up there in
that little prepared blackboard up above
maybe I'll just go through and and check
them out to make sure that we're all on
the same page with them so I'm going to
claim that there's this trig identity at
the top secant squared is 1 plus the
tangent so let's just check that out so
the secant is 1 over the cosine so
secant squared is 1 over cosine squared
and then whenever you see a 1 in
trigonometry you always have the option
of writing it as cosine squared plus the
sine squared
and if I do that then I can divide the
cosine squared into that first term and
I get one plus sine squared over cosine
squared which is the tangent squared so
there you go
that checks the first one that's the
main trig identity that's going to be
behind what I talked about today that's
the trigonometry identity part how about
this piece of this piece of calculus can
we calculate what the derivative of the
tangent of X is actually I'm going to do
that on this board well so the the
tangent of X is sine X divided by cosine
X so I think I was with you when we
learned about the quotient rule
computing the derivative of a quotient
and the rule is you take the numerator
and you multiple sort a Kedah rivet
Avada which is cosine and you multiply
it by the denominator so that gives you
cosine squared and then you take the
numerator take minus the numerator and
multiply that by the derivative of the
denominator which is minus sine of X and
you put all that over the square of the
denominator and now I look at that and
before my eyes I see this same trig
identity cosine squared plus sine
squared is one appearing there this is
one over cosine square root of x which
is secant squared and good so that's
what the claim was the derivative of the
tangent is the secant squared that
immediately gives you an integral namely
the integral of secant squared is the
tangent that's the fundamental theorem
of calculus so we verified the first
integral there well let's just do the
second one as well so if I want to
differentiate the secant
derivative of the secant so that's D DX
of 1 over the cosine and again I have a
quotient this one's a little easier
because the numerator is so simple so I
take the derivative of the numerator
which is 0 and then I take the numerator
I take minus the numerator times the
derivative of the denominator which is
minus sine of X and put all that over
the square of the same denominator so 1
minus saying sine came from the quotient
rule and the other one came because
that's the derivative of the cosine but
they cancel and so I get sine over
cosine squared which is sine over cosine
times 1 over cosine and so that's the
secant that's 1 over the cosine times
the tangent of X so not hard that
verifies that the C derivative of the
secant is secant tangent and it tells
you that the integral of that weird
thing in case you ever want to know the
integral of the secant tangent is the
secant well there are a couple more
integrals that I want to do for you that
that where I can't sort of work
backwards like that let's calculate the
derivative of the tank let's calculate
the integral of the tangent just do this
straight out so the tangent is the sine
divided by the cosine
and now there's a habit of minds that I
hope you get into when you see the
cosine and you're working in and track
calculating an integral like this it's
useful to remember what the derivative
of the cosine is because maybe it shows
up somewhere else in the integral and
that happens here so that suggests we
make a substitution u equals the cosine
of X which means D U is minus the sine
of X DX that's the numerator except for
the minus sign and so I can rewrite this
as under this substitution I can rewrite
this as minus D U that's the numerator
sine X DX is minus D u divided by u ha
well I know how to do that integral -
that gives me the natural log doesn't it
so this is minus the natural log of U
plus a constant I'm not quite done I
have to back substitute and replace this
new variable that I made up called U
with what it is and what you get is
minus the natural log of the cosine of X
so the integral of the tangent is minus
log cosine now I don't you find these
tables of integrals in the back of the
book things like that I'm not sure how
much memorization professor jerison is
going to ask of you but there is a
certain amount of memorization that goes
on in calculus this is one of the kinds
of things that you probably want to know
let me do one more integral I think I'm
making my way through a prepared board
here let's see good so the integral of
the tangent is minus log cosine
I'd also like to know what the integral
of the secant of X is and I don't know a
way to kind of go straight at this but
let me show you a way to think your way
through to it if I take these two facts
tangent prime is what is what it is and
secant prime is what it is and add them
together I get this fact that the
derivative of the secant of X plus the
tangent of X is well it's the sum of
these two things secant secant squared
plus secant tangent and there's a secant
that occurs in both one both of those
terms so I'll factor it out and that
gives me I'll put put it over here
there's the secant of X that occurs in
both terms and then in one term there's
another secant and on the other term
there's a tangent so that's interesting
somehow because this same term appears
on both sides of this equation let's
write you for that secant X plus tangent
of X and so the equation that I get is U
prime equals u times the secant of X of
X I've just made it just made a direct
substitution just decide that I'm going
to write you for that single thing that
occurs on both sides of the equation so
u prime is on the left and u times
secant of X is on the right well there's
my secant that I was trying to integrate
and what it tells you is that the secant
of X is U prime divided by you just
divide both sides by U and I get this
equation u prime divided by u that has a
name I'm not sure that professor jerison
has used this in this class but u prime
over u we'd
actually use something like that it's on
the board right now it's a logarithmic
derivative it is the derivative of the
natural logarithm of U maybe it's easier
to read this from right to left if I
want to calculate the derivative of the
logarithm well the chain rule says I get
the derivative of U times the derivative
of the log function which is 1 over U so
often u prime over U is called the
logarithmic derivative but it's done
what I wanted because it's expressed the
secant as a derivative and I guess I
should put in with that what u is
it's the secant plus the tangent and so
that implies that the integral integrate
both sides that says that the integral
of the secant of X DX is the natural
logarithm of the secant of X plus the
tangent of X so that's the last line in
this little memo that I created that we
can use now for the rest of the class ok
any questions about that trick it's just
me it's a trick I have nothing more to
say about it ok so the next thing I yes
so now I want to make the point that
using these rules and some some some
thought you can in it you can now
integrate most trigonometric polynomials
most things that involve powers of sines
and cosines and tangents and secants and
everything else
for example let's try to integrate the
integral of secant to the fourth
oh that's big power of the secant
function well there are too many
secant's there for me so let's take some
away and I can take them away by using
that trig identity secant squared is 1
plus tangent squared so I'm going to
replace two of those secant's by 1 plus
tangent squared that leaves me with 2
left over now there was method to my
madness because I've got a secant
squared left over there and secant
squared is the derivative of tangent so
that suggests a substitution namely
let's say let's let u be the tangent of
X so that D U is secant squared of X DX
and I have both terms that occur in my
in my integral sitting there very nicely
so this was this the possibility of
making this substitution in seeing a
secant squared up here as part of the
differential here that's why it's it was
a good idea for me to take two of the
secant and write them as 1 plus tangent
squared so now I can continue this under
that substitution I get 1 oh yeah and I
should add the other fact that well I
guess it's obvious that tangent squared
is U squared so I get 1 plus u squared
and then D u the secant square root of x
plus x times DX that is do you well
that's pretty easy to integrate so I get
u Plus u cubed over 3 plus a constant
and then I just have to back substitute
put things back in terms of the original
variables and that gives me tangent of X
plus tangent cubed over three and
there's the answer so we can spend a lot
more time doing more examples of this
kind of trig polynomial trig thing it's
probably best for you to do some
practice on your own because I want to
talk about other things also and what I
want to talk about is the use of these
trig identities in making really trig
trig substitution integration so we did
we did a little bit of this yesterday
and I'll show you some more examples
today let's start with a pretty hard
example right off the bat so this is
going to be the integral of DX over x
squared times the square root of 1 plus
x squared okay it's pretty bad looking
integral so how can we approach this
well the square root is the ugliest part
of the integral I think what we should
try to do is write this square root in
some nicer way that is figure out a way
to write 1 plus x squared as a square
that'll get rid of the square root so
there is an example of a way to write 1
plus something squared in a different
way and it's right up there
secant squared is 1 plus tangent squared
so I want to use that idea and when I
see this form that suggests that we make
us a trig substitution and write X as
the tangent of some new variable which
you might as well call theta because
it's like an angle then 1 plus x squared
is the secant squared according to that
trig identity and so the square root of
1
plus x squared is the secant of theta
right so that's the that's the reason
this this identity is the reason that
the substitution is going to help us
because it gets rid of the square root
and replaces it by some other trig
function I'd better be able to get rid
of the DX - that's part of the
substitution process but we do we can do
that because I know what the derivative
of the tangent is it's secant squared so
DX D theta is secant squared theta so DX
is secant of secant squared theta times
D theta so let's just substitute all
that stuff in and rewrite the entire
integral in terms of our new variable
theta so DX is in the numerator that's
secant squared theta D theta and then
the denominator well it has an x squared
that's tangent squared theta and then
there's this square root and we know
what that is in terms of theta
it's secant secant of theta okay now
we've replaced we've done the trig
substitution I've gotten rid of the
square root I've got everything in terms
of trig functions of the new variable a
pretty complicated trig function this
often happens you wind up with a
complete scattering of different trig
functions in the numerator and
denominator and everything a systematic
thing to do here is to put everything in
terms of sines and cosines
unless you can see right away how it's
going to simplify a systemic thing to do
is to rewrite in terms of sines and
cosines so let's do that so let's see
the secant squared secant is 1 over
cosine so I'm going to put a cosine
squared in the denominator oh I guess
the first thing I can do is cancel let's
do that that's clever you were all
thinking that to cancel those so now I
just get one cosine in the denominator
from the secant there in the numerator
it's still pretty complicated secant
over tangent squared who knows well
we'll find out because the tangent is
sine over cosine so I should put a sine
squared where the tangent was in a
cosine squared up there I still have D
theta and now you see some more
cancellation occurs that's the virtue of
writing things out in this way so now
the square here cancels with this cosine
and I'm left with cosine theta D theta
divided by sine squared theta that's a
little simpler and it puts me in a
position to use the same idea I just
used I see the sign here I might look
around in this integral to see if it's
derivative occurs anywhere the
differential of the sine is the cosine
and so I am very much inclined to make
another substitution say you direct
substitution this time and say use the
cosine of theta because then D you oh
I'm sorry
say you as the sine of theta because
then D U is cosine of theta D theta
and then this integral becomes well the
numerator just is d you the denominator
is you squared and I think we can break
out the champagne because we can
integrate that one finally get rid of
the integral sign yes sir
okay how do I know to make you equal to
sign rather than cosign because I want
to see D you up here up here if I've had
a sign up here that would be a signal to
me that maybe I should say let you be
the cosign okay also because this thing
in the denominator is something I want
to get rid of it's in the denominator so
I'll get rid of it by wishful thinking
and just call it something else
it's and it works pretty well in this
case
wishful thinking doesn't always work so
well but so I integrate you to the minus
2 D U and I get minus 1 over u plus a
constant and I'm done with the calculus
part of this problem I've done the
integral now gotten rid of the integral
sign but I'm not quite done with the
problem yet because I have to work my
way back through two substitutions first
this one and then this one so this this
first substitution isn't so bad to get
rid of to undo to back substitute
because you was just the sine of theta
and so 1 over u is I guess a fancy right
way to write it is this cosecant of
theta right 1 over the sine is the
cosecant so I get minus the cosecant of
theta plus a constant is our question in
the back yes sir
I'm sorry I hear hearing so bad how did
I know this substitution in the first
place the only thing is so it's because
of the 1 plus X squared and I want to
make use of the trig identity in the
upper left hand corner I'll make you a
table in a few minutes that will put all
this in a bigger context and I think
it'll help you then ok I'll promise so
what I want to try to talk about right
now is how to how to rewrite a term like
this a trig term like this back in terms
of X so I want to undo this trig
substitution this is a trig sub and what
I want to do now is try to undo that
trig sub I'll show you a general method
for undoing trig substitutions this
happens quite often I don't know what
the cosecant of theta is but I do know
what the tangent of theta is so I want
to make a relation between them
okay so undoing sub-string subs so let's
go back to where trigonometry always
comes from this right angled triangle
for the theta in the corner and then
these three sides this one's called the
hypotenuse this is when it's called the
adjacent side and that one's called the
opposite side now let's find out where X
lies in this triangle let's try to write
the sides of this triangle in terms of X
and what I know is X is the tangent of
theta so the tangent of theta tangent of
this angle is opposite / adjacent elearn
sohcahtoa okay so it's opposite /
adjacent is the tangent so they're
different they're different ways to do
that but why not just do it in the
simplest way and suppose that the
adjacent is 1
and the opposite is X this is a correct
now isn't it I get the correct value for
the tangent of theta by saying that the
lengths of those are 1 and X and that
means that thye potenuse has length 1
plus x squared well here's a triangle
I'm interested in computing the cosecant
of theta where does that appear in the
triangle well let's see the cosecant of
theta is 1 over the sine and the sine is
opposite over hypotenuse right so the
cosecant is hypotenuse over opposite
right and the hypotenuse is the square
root of 1 plus x squared and the
opposite is X and so I've done it I've
undone the trig substitution I figured
out what this cosecant of theta is in
terms of X and so the final answer is
minus the square root of 1 plus x
squared over X plus a constant and
there's an answer to the original
original problem okay this was a pretty
this took two boards to go through this
is trated several things actually this
3/3 half boards I Illustrated this use
of trig substitution and I'll come back
to that in a second
I Illustrated patients I Ellis traited
rewriting things in terms of sines and
cosines and then making a direct
substitution to evaluate an integral
like this and then there's this undoing
all of those substitutions and it
culminated with undoing the trig subsidy
a let's play a game here
why don't we play the game where you
give me so there's a step in here that I
should have done I should have said this
is - the cosecant of the arc tangent of
theta plus a constant the most
straightforward thing you can do is to
say since X is the tangent of theta that
means that that that sorry if X that
means that theta is the arctangent of X
and so let's just put in theta as the
arc tangent of X and that's what you get
so really what I just did for you was to
show you a way to compute some trig
Pollan's trig function applied to the
inverse of another trig function right i
computed cosecant of the arctangent by
this trick so now let's play the game
where you give me a foot a trig trig
function and an inverse trig function
and I try to compute what the composite
is
okay so who can give me a trig function
has to be one of these fat standard ones
tangent all right how about another one
sine do we have agreement on sine secant
CSC has the best cheer all right so
that's the game we have to compute try
to compute that composite all right
something wrong with this it what is
acceptable mean don't you think that so
the question is isn't this a perfectly
acceptable final answer it's a correct
final answer but this is much more
insightful and after all the original
thing was involving square roots and
things this is the kind of thing you
might hope for is an answer this is just
a nicer answer for sure and likely to be
more useful to you when you go on and
use that answer for something else okay
okay so let's try to do this this undo
undo a trig substitution that involved a
cosecant and I manipulate around and I
find myself trying to find out what's
the tangent of theta so here's how we go
about it I draw this triangle
theta is the angle here this is the
adjacent opposite hypotenuse so the
first thing is how can I make the
cosecant appear here cosecant of X what
dimensions should I give to the sides in
order for the cosecant of X to to a
sorry in order in order for theta to be
the cosecant of X this thing is Theta so
that means that the that means that the
that means that the that the seek that
the cosecant of X that means the
cosecant of theta should be X theta is
the arc cosecant so X is the cosecant of
theta so what I take the sides to be to
get the cosecant cosecant is 1 over the
sine and the sine and the sine is the
opposite over the hypotenuse so I get
hypotenuse over opposite and that's
supposed to be what X is okay so I could
make the opposite anything I want but
the simplest thing is to make it one
let's do that and then what does that
mean about the rest of the sides
hypotenuse would better be X and then
I've recovered this so here's a triangle
that exhibits the correct angle this
remaining side is going to be useful to
us and it is square root of x squared
minus one so I've got a triangle of a of
the correct angle theta and now I want
to compute the tangent of that angle
well that's easy that's opposite /
adjacent and so I get 1 over the square
root of x squared minus 1 very flexible
tool that'll be useful to you in many
different different times whenever you
have to undo a trig substitution this is
likely to be useful
okay that was a good game no winners in
this game we're all winners no losers
we're all winners okay so good yeah so
let me make this table of the different
trig substitutions and how they can be
useful summary trig substitutions so
over here we have if you see so if your
integrand integrand contains
make the substitution to get so if your
integrand contains I'll write these
things out of square roots if it
contains the square root of a squared
minus x squared this is what we talked
about on Thursday when I was trying to
find the area of that piece of a circle
there I suggested that we should make
the substitution X is a times the cosine
of theta or X is a times the sine of
theta either one works just as well and
there's no way to prefer one over the
other and when you make the substitution
X is equal to a kind of times the cosine
of theta you get a squared minus a
squared cosine theta squared theta one
minus cosine squared is the sine squared
and so you get a sine of theta so I've
so this this expression becomes equal to
this expression under that identify
under that substitution and then you go
on then you've gotten rid of the square
root and you've got a trigonometric
integral that you have to try to do if
you made the substitution a sine theta
you'd get a squared minus a sine a
squared sine squared which is a times
cosine Hey and then you can go ahead as
well we just saw another example namely
if you have a squared plus x squared
that's like the example we had up here a
is equal to 1 in this example what did
we do we set we tried the substitution X
is a tangent of theta and the reason is
that I can plug into the trig identity
up here in the upper left and replace a
squared plus x squared by a times the
secant of theta square root of the
secant squared
there's one more thing in this table
it's sort of the only remaining sum or
difference of terms like this and that's
what happens if you have x squared minus
a squared so there I think we can make a
substitution a times the secant of theta
because after all secant squared of
theta so x squared minus a squared sorry
let's see what happens when I make that
substitution x squared minus a squared
is a squared secant squared theta minus
a squared under this substitution that's
secant squared minus 1 well put the 1 on
the other side and you find tangent
squared coming out so this is a squared
times the tangent squared of theta and
so that's what you get a times the
tangent of theta after I take the square
root I get a times the tangent of theta
so these are the basics the three basic
trig substitution forms where trig
substitutions are useful and to get rid
of expressions like this and replace
them by trigonometric expressions okay
and then you use this trick you do the
integral if you can and then you use
this trick to get rid of the theta at
the end
okay so now the last thing I want to set
talk about today is called completing
the square and that comes in because
unfortunately not everything not every
quad square root of a quadratic has such
a simple form you will often encounter
things like that are not just the square
root of something simple like one of
these forms like there might be a middle
term in there and I have an I yeah I
don't actually have time to show you an
example of how this comes out in a sort
of practical example but it does happen
quite frequently and so I want to show
you how to deal with things like the
following example let's try to integrate
DX over x squared plus 4x the square
root of x squared plus 4x so there's a
square root of something some squares
some quadratic it's very much like this
business but it isn't of any of these
forms and so what I want to do is show
you how to rewrite it in one of those
forms using substitution again all this
is about substitution so the game is to
rewrite a quadratic as something like X
plus something or other plus some other
constant so write it try to write it in
the form a square plus or minus another
constant and then we'll go on from there
so let's do that in this case X to the
squared x squared plus 4x well if you
square this form out then the middle
term is going to be to a X and so that
since I I have a middle term here I
pretty much know what a has to be the
only choice in order to get something
like x squared plus 4x out of this is to
take a to be 2 because then this is what
you get this isn't quite right yet but
let's compute what I have here x squared
plus 4x so far so good plus 4 and I
don't have a plus 4 here so I have to
fix that by subtracting 4 so that's what
I mean I've completed the square the
word for this process of eliminating the
middle term by using the square of an
expression like that that's called
completing the square and we can use
that process to compute this integral so
let's do that so I can rewrite this
integral I rewrite this denominator like
this but but but I think it's but and
then I'm going to try to use one of
these forms over here so in order to get
a single variable there instead of
something complicated like X plus 2 I'm
inclined to come up with another
variable name and write you write it
equal write X plus 2 as that other
variable name so here's another little
direct substitution u is x plus 2 figure
out what do u is that's pretty easy and
then rewrite the integral in those terms
so DX is d u and then in the denominator
I have well I have the square root of
that oh yeah so I think as part of this
I'll write out what x squared plus 4x is
the point is it's equal to u square
- four four x squared plus four X is U
squared minus four there's the data a
data box containing this the
substitution data and so now I can put
that in I have x squared plus 4x there
in terms of you that's u squared minus
four well now I'm in a happier position
because I can look for U squared minus
four for something like that in my table
here and it actually sits down here so
except for the use of the letter X here
instead of U over there that tells me
what I want so to handle this what I
should use is a trig substitution in the
trig substitution that suggested is
according to the bottom line with a
equal to two so a squared is four the
suggestion is I should take X but I'd
better not use the letter X anymore oh
but I don't have a letter X I have two
letter U I should take u equal to two
secant and then some letter I haven't
used before and theta is available okay
I've this is a lookup table process I
see this square root of U squared minus
four I see that that's of this form I'm
instructed to make this substitution and
that's what I just did let's see how it
works out so that means the D U is 2
okay what's the derivative of the secant
secant tangent so D u is twice secant
theta tangent theta and u squared minus
four is here's the payoff I'm supposed
to be able to rewrite that in terms of
the tangent according to this u squared
minus four
is for secant squared minus four and
secant squared minus one is tangent
squared so this is four times the
tangent squared of theta right yeah but
I squared it and now I'll square root it
and I'll get it to and this tangent will
go away so there's my data box for this
substitution and let's go on to another
board so where I'm at is the integral of
D u over the square root of U squared
minus four and I have all the I have all
the data I need here to rewrite that in
terms of theta so D U is two secant
theta tangent theta D theta and the
denominator is ten twice the tangent of
theta ha well so some very nice
simplification happens here the twos
cancel and the tangents cancel and I'm
left with trying to work with the
integral of the secant of theta D theta
and luckily enough at the very beginning
of the hour I worked out how to compute
the integral of the secant of theta and
there it is so this is the natural
logarithm of the secant of theta plus
the tangent of theta
plus a constant and we're done with the
calculus part there's no more integral
there but I still I'm not quite done
with the problem because again I have
these two substitutions to try to undo
so let's undo them one by one let's see
I have this trig substitution here and I
could use my triangle trick if I need to
but maybe I don't need to let's see do I
know what the secant of theta is in
terms of you well I do so I get the
natural logarithm of U over 2 do I know
what the tangent is in terms of U
well I do it's here so I lucked out in
this case and I don't have to go through
and use that triangle trick so the
tangent of theta is the square root of U
squared minus 4 over 2 good
so I've undone this trig substitution
not quite done yet because my answer is
involved with you and what I wanted
originally was X but this direct
substitution in the in that I started
with is real easy to deal with I can
just put X plus 2 every time I see a u
and so this is the natural logarithm of
X plus 2 over 2 plus the square root
what's going to happen when I put X plus
2 in place for you here you know what
you get you get exactly what we started
with right I put X plus 2 in place of
the U here I get x squared plus 4x
so I've gotten back to a function purely
in terms of X okay that's a good place
to quit have a great little one-day
break
I guess this class doesn't meet on
Monday anyway but